hi I'm Megan McDowell one of the  producers on SimCity I'm going to show  you how to play offline using the new  single player mode all I have to do is  select single player mode from the main  menu this allows me to play without an  internet connection  in single-player mode I can still build  in control of multiple cities and share  resources between my cities all while  playing offline since all single-player  games are saved locally I can save any  time experiment with my cities and  easily revert back to it I would save  for example I can completely destroy my  city and then bring it back to life our  new single-player mode adds a whole new  dimension to SimCity giving you more  freedom to play the way you want now if  I want to go back and play one of my  multiplayer cities I'll just need to  return to the main menu and select  multiplayer mode it's that simple  thanks for watching I hope you have fun  playing offline